are you good how are you what's your
name
Jeanne what you my name is mark nice to
meet you
so and I don't babies really yes
you want to make a little bit of money
yes I do uh I don't know if I'm
interested in that thank you but but I'd
like to your photograph okay that's fine
my studio is right around the corner
okay hop in alright Jamie Jamie Jamie
version Long Beach it was really long
business I mean going along between that
we got hot rice when I was three times
13 are you really gonna date me I did
how long have you been here oh Sid um
since 13 until I'm 34 now yeah I have
how'd you get here
my dad my my mom broke up with her
husband but she found a new husband as
they either could have moved to the cold
weather she didn't want to move there so
my dad my mom found her name's what
husband out of church and they've been
that he raised me he was read dad but he
was out coughing so they bought you
don't you don't want to be back he's
with his family
that's the golfer so they take all the
vitamin B to California where my family
is honesty I was spoiled I had the best
childhood ever I was we were over here
just I went to close it it was wait I
was spoiled his kids yeah but I became I
felt like the black sheep of the family
family and I taught myself to see life
and I did cheat I taught myself the
sheets living on fire myself
because I felt like left out a little
bit you know I don't know because I was
baby I always got picked on at school
and I would
like I was like especially I would like
always behind and I was because of my
voice my daily becomes ten names about
my boys why you know I was born with it
yeah yes he would call me pepperoni face
carvings polish of I felt like a black
sheep of the family so I did the speech
she like when I was excited when I was
20 21
yeah but I lived with my longtime foot I
said it on crystal meth then I moved to
cocaine yeah you know let me been doing
crack and crystal meth when you start
with drugs um 20 21 is when I started a
crystal then 2013 I went to black so
however many years that is three done
till now I'm really black then what do
you do for money no parts my my parents
are still there for me they still see me
what you can't bring me close with me
whatever I need and still give me my
allowance because I still get to check
but he's still really I was once a week
to none of these women down you don't
have the parents because of what they do
my pills are dedicated needed to bring
out search parties to find me since I
hung with you because I'm the baby and
anyone because I'm thrilled I know I
don't you know you feel me I know I was
messing with my last about my uncle they
always said when you're molested when
you get gonna make me do prostitution
not eight seven eight nine years old
yeah did you know you can tell your bar
I did eventually they got ways so as we
told him cuz I'm scared to tell her you
know because I don't want her novel easy
with her brother you know what I mean it
was hard you know but I don't really
want to talk about it I have five
brothers didn't see I have five brothers
and one sister
and I make seven so five others to sit
through one sister said that seven
others I have nine nieces and nephews
that I only met two of them with no baby
and all six seven eight years old no no
I was playing it for it every time
in two years I got a voice in and one
miscarriage because I'm my mom and I
when we have a baby I'm not responsible
not because I have a child of mine I'm
not responsible can't raise a shot
especially when I lived on the streets
like this yes I do I get checked every
three months I was always negative you
know so i'ma buy and you know good genes
throughout my my family you know so we
never had ever
we're always healthy my family was 97
years old so cold so clean clean doors
I've never used a walker cane or a
wheelchair whatever and she always
complains but I said she never learned
how to drive or swim and she was I
neither seven years old still cooking
cleaning for herself never grains but I
say
I'm all day in your bed my mom doesn't
look like my grandma doesn't look Paige
I'm sorry I just turned 34 I mean it's
dangerous here was thinking of guys on
the street no I ain't not resourceful I
do I had some tragic ones but it wasn't
that tragic like they were Drive they
were trevor you you know you know throw
me like a football like you know
something
bring me a be silly I don't think my
ready back and then one guy like me J
yeah nobody like this throwing against
you know because they'll just revisit of
it
yeah they write me and I don't like what
they're doing so they just true and take
my money in their money and like this
one guy was I was trying to get out
student help trying to get like one or
two people that while on the seat tell
attention you know and he goes 65 City
but I like it 20 15 20 miles speed limit
zone and I've to open the car and I did
leave we get out during that speech
because he was later he's hurting me
yeah so and I had a twice a gun pulled
on me and when a gunshot a bullet would
wipe a three and a night full of all the
stuff but I just posilutely
thank you thank you for talking yellow
foam fairy story no problem it's a
little bit of a joke but a lot more but
we don't have time to take